our good friend back on the program
hanging out with Chris Rose who no doubt
is flipping out over all what's gone
down with his Browns and Cavs over the
last couple of days but the man you can
watch with Chris murrow's on MLB
network's intentional talk at 3:30 p.m.
Eastern and again at 5:00 throughout the
offseason he's Kevin Millar back here on
the program how are you Kevin okay so I
guess I'll ask it to you now that we
know it is complete and that the Red Sox
are bringing home another trophy for the
case that a run that you are part of the
beginning of back in the day how'd they
do it how did they do it you know what
they have a model in that in that
Clubhouse and it's humble with that it's
a group of guys especially now you just
send their ball players and they have
humble bats which means they're working
for the next guy behind them in this day
in age like I said it's tough because
the money is so big and their
selfishness going on in home run today
or whatever it is but it was a very
unique situation being around these guys
from been intended to Jackie Bradley jr.
and Mookie Betts and JD Martinez your
two stars very humble they put together
a group like Brock Hulk it's for the
cycle in the postseason but they
tremendous at-bats and grind you all the
way through and then you look up and
they had a hundred and what 19 wins well
when it's all said and done with the
World Series trophy and 108 wins leading
the league this year so if they work
they were underdogs a few of the games
in Dodger Stadium you know and it's just
like they don't get the credit
so John Henry said afterwards Kevin that
it's the best Red Sox team ever as
somebody who broke the jinx in 2004
would you agree they're the most wins
ever I you know it's hard because our oh
four team and not you know listen I
played on that team I knew the group of
guys we're very similar so I used a very
similar type team to say it's better
it's always better when you know they
just won I don't know if you can say
better I mean you got you got a lot of
Hall of Famers on our team and in the
run that we had being down three games
to none to the Yankees and winning four
straight against them and then going in
and sweeping the Cardinals who were the
best team in the big leagues that year I
think they like honored five wins and we
were a wild-card team it's hard to
say better especially a first
championship in 86 years and you know
Pedro Martinez and Manny Ramirez David
Ortiz Curt Schilling I mean there was a
group of guys out there with some star
power but we were just a bunch of
regular guys also so I would say better
I would say very similar so who would
you peg right now is potential Hall of
Famers on the Red Sox team that just won
the most wins that you point out well if
I was to point somebody out you're
looking at Mookie Betts I mean he could
be one of the top three players
obviously in the big leagues right now
and who knows with his athletic ability
how long this is going to go but he is a
star
I mean jteem Arkansas turned himself
into the best right-hand hitter over the
last couple years and really figured
something out whatever that is whatever
that secret medicine I'm sure he shared
it with the team this year because he
got better through Miguel Cabrera and
taking that over to Boston in his first
year so he could be a potential guy you
know they got me David Price you got it
you got it hats of what he's gone
through and the whole Owen nine in the
postseason his last three starts boom
three no he's through and what four the
five games you know in this game or
three out of the five whatever it was I
mean as a bullpen and starting so
there's a lot of great stories
Porcello Chris Sale out of bullpen
Ivaldi are you kidding me with that
bullpen situation on the 18-inning game
97 pitches night you know and he was
ready to throw the next day todas Quorra
so you just they had a lot of guys that
looked outs and eyes that I'm available
however UDP and that's when you check
that you go in so do you think Kevin
Millar here on the Rich Eisen show since
you know you mentioned Betts is a a
potential hall-of-famer and then went
down a list and and and I guess the the
names diminished from there to be very
honest with you do you think this team
is built for the the era of bull penning
and the era of where everybody else
either walks or homers or strikes out
that this team makes contact and that
they had a manager that push buttons
knowing that I guess is this built for
the analytics era this Red Sox team they
have a little bit of both I don't think
I just think the analytics you know you
can't go all-in with it you can't go a
full season with an entire bullpen scene
you can go a short series the Brewers
prove that that they can compete with
that but when
talking about a 162 games schedule and
not everybody's got the same finances
and you understand that but the starter
is important and I know we've gotten out
of it for a second but you need guys to
go longer in two games for the long
season or those bullpen arms will be out
unless you're going to keep rotating
guys and then it gets real real kind of
dicey when you're talking about how do
you pay a starter how do you pay a
Dallas Keuchel who's gonna hit free
agency this year you know the good
starter's been a great starter you know
and I saw a young guy and you're looking
out there now our starter is not valued
but boy when you got a big game in the
postseason you need that starter to give
you some depth I know four and five
innings you know was a big deal this
year we saw seven Reno for the Yankees
you know go 40s and he was standing
ovations Yankee baby we've got booth
very very interesting dynamic
information wise in all sports give us
the information but you still got to
have the I guess rich we still can't
lose sight of that and watch the game so
do you think your buddy Dave Roberts
made the right move with Rich Hill in in
Game four or that's just 20/20 hindsight
obviously yeah I think Dave Roberts you
know he's got a lot of heat and maybe
not deserved because behind the scenes I
know there's a lot of information being
given to him and from the front office
down so you know they say hey putting
alexander immediately if Rich Hill goes
lefty on lefty is it something that they
you know Matson bring him in I mean I'm
sure Dave get to make those decisions
and those decisions didn't work out but
you know there's there are decisions
you're going to get questioned on and
I'm sure that Rich Hill decision didn't
work out so he's going to get questioned
on he got question on that last year
against the Astros when Rich Hill went
to four innings and gave up one run
seven strikeouts and they brought him in
and brought in Brandon Morrow and it
didn't work out and so if it works out
you're great you know Alex Cora
pinch-hit home run by Mitch Moreland
three run home on looks like a genius so
you're only as good as your players
doing their job and the job that the
bullpen you know didn't do the job Ferb
Dave Robertson Dodgers Kevin Millar here
on the Rich Eisen show so what
what would you do if your the Dodgers
that's two years in a row that made the
World Series and they fall short Kershaw
could opt out Manny Machado can walk
what do you think they should do well I
don't think Kershaw is gonna opt out I
think you have a star in Walker Buehler
we saw that it's almost like a changing
of the guards now
I mean tremendous presence for a young
guy last year he's watching the World
Series with his sister in the stands
this year he's pitch and going 8 innings
of basically a few hits and dominating
and lost to a Jackie Bradley two-out
home run well Anna bland that game I
believe but you know Jackie probably
tying it off can Lee jams in the 8th so
they have a lot of positives you have
Corey Seager coming back they're gonna
have to you know they're gonna sign a
Manny Machado back who knows they have
you know just in turn they have a nice
team but there are some things that they
just haven't gotten over that hump would
you do it the will would you want to
keep Machado if you're the Dodgers you
got Seager in my opinion you got a young
stud shortstop I don't know if you need
to spend the the the big dough I don't
know what his salary is going to dictate
we've we've heard anywhere from two
three four hundred million dollars for
Bryce harbors and Machado's the money is
crazy to me right I don't know but I'm
sure Manny Michels and go out there and
have a few teams but if I'm the Dodgers
of course Seger's healthy you have a
young bad shortstop that I'm sure it has
a high ceiling okay what if you're the
Yankees what moves do you make this
offseason Kevin Millar now that's that
that's where it gets interesting right
obviously they're gonna be in a Machado
there's only a handful of teams that can
afford a man my child look I know didi
Gregorius has got the arm surgery and
they'd have no idea but what why would
they do that
I mean I've no idea why they would do
that they need is Machado gonna be a
starter is he is he gonna pitch I mean
that makes no sense to me it's big the
only make sense because they're one of
the organizations that have the big
dough so anybody that's a big price it's
linked to the Yankees maybe they're not
involved right we should say that
because they're one of the Dodgers the
Phillies the Yankees the Red Sox you
know can afford a big price ticket type
player like Machado it's just who needs
them so that's where it becomes
interesting especially when Bryce
Harper's available I mean where's he end
up
so I'm sure it's gonna be a domino
effect hmm and I guess last one for you
Kevin what do you think the Astros
should do what do you think what do you
think the post-mortem on the defending
World Series champs no more season would
be yeah there's such a great team
they're almost like you thought they
were like a dynasty type with that staff
Alex Bregman that leadership that he's
brought Altuve Korea bad bag didn't have
a great years because he bounced back
Springer
they have stars they have young stars I
don't think they do anything other than
they might add see what Tyco happens to
Tyco and maybe replace him but when with
Charlie Morton and and and Verlander and
you got foundation I Lance McCullers if
he's healthy he's as good as anybody yep
Gerrit Cole still there so they're in a
good spot I think now they just kind of
they piece together a few bullpens here
and there we all learn from bullpen
situations every year we saw salt in
2014 with the Royals when they had that
run it started with the bullpen it kind
of started changing how free agencies
you know guys in the Beaumont's are
getting money they started finally
getting paid the 20 million bucks that
bullpen guys never really got paid he's
going to the parade Kevin oh I am in
Austin Texas okay nice to be home
Halloween and I'll be watching on TV
just like everybody else who are you
gonna who are you going for to Halloween
we gonna be well I got I got four little
dudes yep
if I go as Kevin Millar just go you know
I black would that meet with that be
just really bad it's called uninspired
Kevin that's what it's called it's
called uninspired and you're better than
that
I'll be very honest with you that's
right you're better than that alright
come on I'm gonna target Zainab I'll
grab a costume I'll let you know I'm
good how about this you could go in a
Red Sox uniform and go as bet losing
a-rod you could do that see what I'm
saying like see now that's inspired at
least if you're gonna be good just tap
out and use a Red Sox outfit you could
just be inspired and say you're a rod or
lost a bet yeah papi a shot out in that
situation by the way that was a great
you can half a billion dollars Ritchie
and he's in a Red Sox uniform you could
you could just you could also you know
play New York New York on a boombox and
see you around judge you could do that
too now do you think that really meant
something because I know they played
that in the in the clubhouse in Los
Angeles when they're partying the World
Series do you really think that that
inspired them Kevin there's always
there's always a little something you
write on the Billboard and inspires you
it doesn't mean that oh yeah now we're
gonna try harder you know but yeah it's
kind of fun there's always gets going on
with every team so that worked out in
their favor and it was a great gift for
the Sox
okay all right Kevin you know thanks for
joining
really appreciate it this is fun you got
it right back at ya we'll chat again
soon that's Kevin Millar hair on the
Rich Eisen show the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience